here we go hey see you along my name is
taylor sinclair
and a singler and i appreciate your
your wild little voice hitting these
lines brother
and you sound like something very uh
like a good person and i want to hear
more from you let's go daddy
i was born a premature baby only born
one pound 11 ounces
whoa and that is very one pound
one pound 11 ounces man that's
dude that's like a dang that ain't even
as big as
well i got this snicker right here and
this is a
slice and share snickers
and this was given to me this was a
hand-given gift in
um lexington kentucky and this is a
snickers candy and this thing is
16 ounces so you were
if you said one pound one ounce let me
hear what you said again boy
jesus man you're just a little [ __ ]
stallion bro i've had potatoes bigger
than you bro you're a damn side item
onward
i was born a premature baby only born
one pound eleven ounces
oh one pound 11 ounces so that's
more than this but this is one pound of
snicker
so you was maybe a little bit bigger
than this gigantic snicker right here
and that's and that's crazy to think
about
think about you was just a damn barely
bigger
than a large snicker and you were living
imagine if god put life into a snicker
candy
imagine if the lord just zapped that
[ __ ] fatty sweet right there
and that [ __ ] just walked off and grew
up
and had snacks and everything and ate
you know and did life
imagine if a snicker was in school or
broke its arm on the monkey bars or
you know knocked a knocked up a twix in
the 11th grade and had to drop
out and work at the gas station
imagine that could that could happen if
god put the
you know the life source into a snickers
but he put it into you and you were just
barely bigger than this candy that's
[ __ ] damn startling bro god damn dude
i feel like a damn wolf just [ __ ] my
brain man let's hear more
oh i'll be sending you guys something
through the mail
let me show you pictures of what a
little guy was man i could only fit in a
cabbage patch clothes
no joke oh wow so you was
and we had a boy by us um
kenneth was his name and his parents
would put him in
uh he was very small something had
happened to him i don't know
and he got born i mean he probably only
had about half a cup of blood in his
body
you know and maybe damn six teaspoons of
plasma or something
right you could probably i mean his legs
was damn look like two big buffalo wings
you know breaded
and his parents used to get doll
clothing for him
double extra and triple extra large uh
teddy bear t-bear clothing so you'd see
him with a damn
you know a little shirt on it would say
uh mr bear on the back
you know a lot of his clothes says [ __ ]
like that you know um
or it would say uh get well because he
would get a lot of
you know they would he would get a lot
of gift shops teddy bears have little
shirts on them
from hospitals people get that little
get somebody of a little [ __ ] polar
bear said get well on the shirt
and he would have that shirt on you see
him with that little like damn all his
shirts say get well
because his parents was getting double
extra and triple extra and quad xls
large uh you know uh plush
animal clothing clothing off of [ __ ]
gift shop animals
and putting them onto that boy so i've
seen stuff like that but hot
diggity damn that's wild to think he was
wearing cabbage patch clothing
onward uh i've been a big listener to
your podcast and listening to stand-up
comedy for a while now
i love your unique style and how you
reach out to people and try to help them
in any way possible
um today is the best news of my life
today i just got approved for uh rehab
um i've been drinking my life away for
damn near a decade
being piece of [ __ ] and whatnot and uh
i'm starting today's thursday the 27th
so
i'm starting uh going into the new year
with the right direction and the right
foot
wow man congratulations
you know god made you small but man you
have a really big opportunity ahead of
you
you know there is an opportunity
for you to have just a new experience
with life
you know imagine if all of the fears and
all the uncertainties
imagine if they just
just just just
left you just fell out of you
and i mean fell away so far away so
quickly
that you forgot they ever even existed
i'm talking about the the uncertainties
and the self-loathing and the
the low self-confidence if those things
that probably spin around in your head a
lot imagine if they disappeared
so quickly and so
and i mean gone like they stole a damn
the last slice of pie
and you ca so and they disappeared so
much that you
couldn't even remember that you had them
these ghosts that have been living
inside of you
for damn near whatever a lot of your
life
imagine if they disappeared well i'm
telling you bro
from my own experience i'm not preaching
at you but i'm just saying
that uh through recovery and stuff that
could be a possibility
so that's amazing damn i think you go
from wearing cabbage patch clothes
to actually running mr mcgregor's garden
different type of environment man you
can have a new experience
congratulations brother and thank you
for sharing that
that news with us you just made is
boosting my spirits
god damn dude make me touch my own chest
and the cool thing about my i got a
chest of a damn
you know a [ __ ] you know a falcon
with [ __ ] heartburn
you know i got a
i got a damn i got a chest like a
[ __ ] canary that's uh
you know been doing only chest and
always you know
can't get there on leg day
but thank you for your call man let's
take another call here 985-664-9503 is
the number
good evening good afternoon and other
times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one